Opie Hughes is colorblind and his
emotional reaction to seeing the full
color spectrum on outrageous acts of
science really tugged at our
heartstrings I bet so much so that we
decided to try the experiment on our
very own colorblind guinea pig engineer
Mike North I'm really excited to try
these this has been a disability that
I've lived with my entire life and to
think that there's something that could
help correct it I'm pretty excited I
want to give this a shot
well it certainly changes things well
that's obviously red obviously purple
it's also when my mind's having a hard
time processing what's coming into it
whoa whoa now that's different wow
there's so much color in my hands wow
that really changes it
come on adjust sit down on the box of
crayons and see what they look like but
watching colors look like outside the
studio we set my free to check out the
big wide colorful world Wow
I'm parking red zones yeah the figure I
can always get out of the ticket you
know what's really different is the
traffic lights with these on that is
Green Green Green Green Green without
him sound like it's kind of like a white
blueish for the tinge of green to it
maybe Wow
oh and that's red wow that's a pretty
sunset so uh no more excuses for parking
in the red zone now mine okay